DINA PORTMAN: Hi, Martin.
Are you busy?
MARTIN OMANDER: I'm free.
DINA PORTMAN: I was
wondering if it's
possible to call a private Cloud
Function from a Google Compute
Engine instance.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yes, it is.
I'll show you how.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So Dina, out of
curiosity, why do you
want to know about calling
a private Cloud Function?
DINA PORTMAN: OK.
After the big HR outage
we had last week,
our manager wants us to move
the on-prem HR application
to the cloud, and she wants
us to re-architect it using
service-oriented architecture.
I'm a little overwhelmed
over where to start.
I have a feeling we'll have to
use private Cloud Functions.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK,
let's think about it.
We have two main challenges.
How do we move the
app to the Cloud,
and then how do we migrate to a
service-oriented architecture?
DINA PORTMAN: Right.
But remember, our HR
application is written in COBOL.
It's not exactly a runtime that
cloud providers usually cover.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah, good point.
I know.
Give me some Mountain
Dew and six weeks,
and I'll rewrite the
whole thing in Python.
DINA PORTMAN: [LAUGHS] I'm
not sure that's a good idea.
We know from the DORA
research that applications
are more stable and
have fewer incidents
if we roll out small
changes frequently.
Six weeks of refactoring
and one big push
sounds like a
recipe for a crash.
With that many lines
of code, how are you
even going to isolate the bugs?
And the system won't stand
still in the meantime.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah, good point.
Cooler heads prevail.
Oh, here's another idea.
What if we load the app
as-is into a virtual machine,
and then we peel off services
over time that we can put
into Google Cloud Functions?
For instance, we could start
with the vacation requester.
DINA PORTMAN: I love that idea.
I think it'll work,
but we'll have
to use private Cloud
Functions, because we
don't want just anyone messing
with our vacation requests.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
So now I see why
you want to know
how to get a virtual machine
to talk to a private Cloud
Function.
All right.
So our plan is to migrate
the app to a virtual machine
and then break out one
service to a Cloud Function.
But first, we need to validate
that the virtual machine is
able to call a private
Cloud Function.
DINA PORTMAN: I say let's
test it out with a default
hello, world function, and I can
do a curl to the Cloud Function
URL from the virtual machine.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Sounds good to me.
DINA PORTMAN: OK.
I will start by making
the Cloud Function.
Here we go--
Create.
And to be extra
special sure, I'm
going to set it to
Require Authentication.
I'll save that.
And to internal traffic only.
I want to use
internal traffic only
to block any external
requests, and I
want to require
authentication to ensure
no unauthorized internal apps
have access to my service.
MARTIN OMANDER: All
right, sounds good.
Looks like your
function deployed.
And now click it and let's check
the Trigger link to make sure
that it denies our request.
DINA PORTMAN: Ah, yes.
It's blocking my
request, so we know
that our settings are working.
MARTIN OMANDER: An error message
we wanted to see-- excellent.
So now, let's send it
some internal traffic
from a virtual machine.
DINA PORTMAN: OK.
I'll create a new
virtual machine.
Here we go--
Create instance.
Just leave all these defaults
on, scroll to the bottom,
and I'm going to use the
default service account.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Why does it matter
which service account you use?
DINA PORTMAN: Oh, good question.
For the authentication,
we need to use
a service account
that has permission
to invoke our function.
The default compute service
account has this by default
if you're also using the default
settings on the Google Cloud
Function side.
Of course, these permissions
are all configurable,
but we can talk about
that another time.
MARTIN OMANDER: Got it.
DINA PORTMAN: OK.
I'm going to SSH into it
and try pinging my function.
First, I need my URL.
Let's copy this.
Copy Link.
And we're just going
to do a curl call here.
curl.
Oh, it's saying
forbidden, 403 error.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah, right.
Don't forget the
Authorization header.
DINA PORTMAN: Oh, yeah.
I forgot.
OK, so I'm going
to run this again.
Just going to add my
Authorization header.
It worked.
MARTIN OMANDER: So now
you're able to call
from a virtual machine
in the same project
if you have the
Authorization header.
Just to be sure, let's
try the same command
from your desktop machine.
DINA PORTMAN: 403.
Awesome.
We can access the function from
inside the virtual machine,
but not from the
public internet.
MARTIN OMANDER: Wonderful.
How would we do this from
inside an application,
instead of using curl?
DINA PORTMAN: That's
a great question.
For service-to-service
requests, we can either
write a direct call
to the metadata server
or we can use one of
the Google Auth Client
libraries, which will
construct this call for you.
The client libraries cover C#,
Go, Java, Node.js, PHP, Python,
and Ruby.
MARTIN OMANDER: Amazing.
I think we have
enough information
to make our project proposal.
DINA PORTMAN: Oh,
man, I completely
forgot about the COBOL.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ugh.
We better get working on
that vacation requester.
We're going to
need it after this.
[MUSIC PLAYING]